my favorite way to tell whether or not I
want to buy something especially when I
had less money was I would translate the
price tag into how many hours it would
take me to make the money all of a
sudden when a shirt looks like nine and
a half hours you're like I don't know if
I would do it for that or a pair of
shoes is a day and a half or two days of
work all of a sudden I'm a lot more
hesitant because I think to myself if a
boss came to me and was like Hey you get
these new kicks but you got to give me
two days of work I don't know if I want
to do that and it was one of the
strongest Behavior changes I had in
terms of controlling my spending